the icon award tonight congratulations
thank you
what does that mean to you what does
that word mean to you and to be
recognized by your fellow artists um
icon usually means you've been around a
long time and i have been around a long
time but um
i'm appreciative of the length of my
career and it's all really down to the
fans and the radio
stations and play my music um and
generally my love of music
and the willingness to carry on and try
and be supportive to
newer acts and you know i've been a fan
of music all my life
and i still buy my records and my cds
and my vinyl
um i don't stream and i don't download
i'm still
a bit of a luddite like that but it
gives me uh the incentive to keep up
yeah to look to uh new artists to
provide me with energy
um and radio is so magical i mean when i
first came to america radio
wow we had one radio station in england
and we come to america and then the
start of fm radio as well
it's it was astonishing and radio
sounded so good in the car
and i still listen to radio in the car
when i'm in england um
it's it's something magical about
hearing for the something on the first
time
for the first time on radio i remember
hearing don't you want me baby by
humanly
and pulling over it was so good on the
brown sugar by the rolling stones so
radio is a magical part of our lives and
none of us artists would be here without
it
well you had some incredible artists
honoring you tonight oh yeah
brandy her how do you feel seeing them
sing your songs and why those three her
is just
so innovative and so brilliant great
guitarist
so many things she can do um and she won
the oscar this year which is fantastic
so it was kind of i won the oscar last
year
she won the oscar and we're both in the
same theater and demi of course is a
dear sweetheart who um
i've been so fond of for a long long
time randy has been a friend of mine for
a long time i'm just i've been a fan of
her for a long time i've played on her
records a long time ago
they represent three different uh
sections of music to me
um and they all sang three the three
songs which are so hard to sing benny
don't let the sun
and i'm still standing they did a
brilliant job so i'm very touched when
someone else sings your song
it's always a compliment no matter
whether you like the version or not
or when you get into an elevator and you
hear music play your song and think
god that's amazing i wrote that
sometimes you forget you know
and to see other artists on the show
like um aj i'd never met them before and
megan the stars
who i've seen for ages and ava max
um and of course uh little nazix who is
a hero of mine
so um it's uh it's wonderful to be able
to be amongst those artists and say
hello for the first time
because you know i listen to these
artists all the time so when you meet
another artist
you pay your respects well here's the
thing every single person who i spoke to
on the red carpet about you
had a story about how you'd given them a
call or you'd
met them and said i loved your music
they all had these incredible stories
how you took the time to know who they
were and know their music
and i'm so impressed by that and i just
wondered how do you find the time and
why is it so important for you to mentor
these other artists when i first came to
los angeles in august
1970 i played the true below club neil
diamond volunteered to introduce me
brian wilson was in the audience i think
crosby stills and nash before the big
crosby still in that
linda ronstadt was there um
and so many people paid me compliments
at the early stages of my career i'm
riding with bernie um
the band came to see me george harrison
wrote me a note
and it gave me um validity of what i was
doing was good
and i was so touched and it inspired me
to continue
and and i thought if these people who
are my heroes like me
then i'm i must be doing good so i've
learned
from that and i think that whenever you
hear something or whenever you see
something whether it's a
a movie a play a dance
a photograph a piece of art you should
phone that person up if it affects you
because
they should be told because we're very
shy as artists about telling each other
how good they are and it's just
fantastic to i've made so many friends
from doing that
um and i love doing it and uh i will
always continue to do that because it's
what you should do
and you know these are some of these
artists i don't know how they do it
i mean billy eilish at 15 lord at 16
kid leroy i mean these kids are rocking
it i i was
just barely shaving when i was sleeping
so
music has been my life it's been
something that's carried me through
sadness and happiness and joy
and it still does i'm still buying all
my new releases every week i listen to
things i do a radio show i'm nearly
coming up to 300 in a row
on my apple show and it's given me the
chance to hear new artists
call them up and say hi i'm really love
what you do
can you come on the show and i can talk
to you so music does that it's been the
saviour of my life
[Music]